[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قد نظن ان السؤال الهويه
والحاحها وقلقها يغيب احيانا في خضم
الاغتراب والاندماج والحياه الناجحه لكنه
يابى الا ان يكون حاضرا ومستفزا اينما ذهب
المرء وهذا تحديدا مرتبطه بحياه
البروفيسورا اماني جمل عميده كليه الشؤون
العامه والدوليه في جامعه برينستون
واستاذه العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه في الجامعه والمدير السابقه لمركز
ممدوحة للسلم والعدل كانت قضيتها على
الدوام ومجال بحثها وتدريسها هو الشرق
الاوسط قضاياها البارزه في التحول
الديمقراطي والعداله والمساواه والحياه
الكريمه لذا تجدها تدير ورشه عمل التنميه
السياسيه العربيه مع الجامعه الامريكيه في
بيروت وتؤسس كمحققه رئيسيه في الباروميتر
العربي احد اضخم المشاريع الاحصائيه
والراي العام في البلاد العربيه الفت جمال
عددا من الكتب اهمها معوقات الديمقراطيه
الجانب الاخر راس المال الاجتماعي في
فلسطين والعالم العربي وكتاب عن
الامبراطوريات والمواطنين ديمقراطيه
مواليه لامريكا ام لا ديمقراطيه على
الاطلاق عينت اماني جمال في عام 2004 عضوا
لمده خمسه اعوام في مجلس العلاقات
الخارجيه وهي عضو في اللجنه الاستشاريه
للعلاقات بين الولايات المتحده والمسلمين
التابعه لمعهد الولايات المتحده للسلام
اختيرت في عام 2006 للحصول على لقب باحثه
كارنيج المرموقه تدور اهتماماتها حول
الراي العام والتحول الديمقراطي المشاركه
المدنيه العلاقات الدوليه المراه والنوع
الاجتماعي السلوك الانتخابي الحوكمه
والمهاجرون واخيرا الدين والسياسه وقد
حازت على عدد من الجوائز والزملات ابرزها
جائزه الكويت في مجال العلوم الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه من مؤسسه الكويت التقدم
العلمي البروفيسوره اماني جمال ضيف الحلقه
الثانيه من المقابله
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه الحلقه الجديده من المقابله وهي
الجزء الثاني مع الدكتور اماني جمال عميده
كليه الشؤون الدوليه والعامه في جامعه
برنستون هنا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واحده من افضل الجامعات
الامريكيه وعلى مستوى العالم وايضا
الدكتوره تبوات منصب العماده وهو منصب
اكاديمي مرموق مرحبا بك دكتوره اهلا اهلا
سعداء بوجودك
وبعودتك للعربيه نحن نفعل في المقابله كما
فعل والدك في عام 1980 حينما اراد ان
تتعلم العربيه لكنك تتحدثين العربيه بشكل
ممتاز جدا الله يخليك
في الحلقه الاولى تحدثنا عن الجوانب
الشخصيه وعن مسيرتك الاكاديميه وكيف وصلت
الى هذا الموقع الاكاديمي في جامعه في
غايه الاهميه نتحدث الان عن انتاج الفكري
انت مهتمه بالديمقراطيه كتبت الكتاب الاهم
عن معوقات الديمقراطيه حاز على جائزه افضل
كتاب في العلوم السياسيه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ماذا يتضمن هذا الكتاب
عن العقوبات الموجوده في الدول العربيه
لعدم الديمقراطيه
وعدم التعزيز الديمقراطي في الدول العربيه
يعني من المفاهيم بالاكاديميه هون بالغرب
انه في يكون في نقص بالمجتمع المدني
الفلسطيني
العربي يعني هم يعزون عدم تقدم
الديمقراطيه لاشكاليه في المجتمع المدني
لذلك منظمات
ومجتمع المدني والمجتمعات التطوعيه عنا
بالدول العربيه موجوده بكثره ماذا نقصد
مجتمع المدني مؤسسات مجتمع مدني يعني لكان
انه في نقص من المجتمع المدني مش من اسس
او
قيمات
اتجاه الديمقراطيه ولكن المجتمعات
المؤسسات المجتمعيه مش مش مدعومه ماديا
وكمان معظم
المؤسسات المجتمع المدني لهم خط
الى الحكومات الى خط للحكومات المحليه او
الحكومات الاعلى ولكن بدون العربيه
القطاع المجتمع المدني
ليس مؤثرا ليس مؤثرا لانه منفصل من الحياه
السياسيه طيب خلينا نعقد مقاربه انا يعني
عندنا اشكاليه الان في معوقات الديمقراطيه
انتم من ناحيه اكاديميه انت ذهبت الى
المجتمع المدني وهذه من زاويه امريكيه
بحثيه
الان الان
ما الفرق بين واقع المجتمع المدني في
العالم العربي وفي الدول الديمقراطيه يعني
ملكنا
هاي المشكله ملكناش انه في فرق كبير بس
لانه ما كانش في ستريز
الدراسات على المجتمع المدني العربي كان
انه المفهوم انه ما فيش مجتمع مدني من فعل
انه لو الشعوب العربيه كانت يعني تهتم
وتشارك بالحياه اليوميه الحياه السياسيه
اليوميه والحياه الاجتماعيه اليوميه ربما
تتيسر امور الديمقراطيه كانه هذه نظره
منقوصه دكتوره لانه الناس تشارك وتذهب
للسجن بسبب
لا لما صار يعني
لما سقطت السوفيتي يونيون
الناس راحوا تظهروا بالشوارع طب احنا
لما انهارت بال 1989 كان اوريدي خطط
الديمقراطيه ماشيه
النظام الشيوعي كان يعني كتير صار دئيل
ومش يعني مش مش
والخطه الدماغيه هي كانت ماشيه بالشعوب
ماشيين فيها قبل سقوط الاتحاد قبل السكون
ولكن في فلسطين ما هو واقع المجتمع المدني
الفلسطيني المجتمع المدني
الفلسطيني وكان من
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومن الفلسطينيه لما
اجت ما هو المجتمع المدني من المؤسسات
التي درستها يعني كل كل المجتمعات المدنيه
كانت المجتمع المدني تتعلق بالشباب بحقوق
المراه
بالقراءه
يعني الحياه الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه في فلسطين كتير كانت معتمده
في وقت اصله قبل وقت اصله من بين الاحتلال
لفتره اصله كانت معتمد على الحياه المجتمع
المدنيه ما كانش في عقوبه ما كانش في
حكومه تمثل الشؤون الفلسطينيه ولا احد
يدعم ولا حدا يدعم يعني مزبوط كان دايما
يجي دعم من الدول العربيه
يعني اهل الخليج كان دائما يدعموا يعني
تبرعات
وكان يجي دعم
في تونس مش موجوده منظمه التحرير ولكن
الشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه وغزه كانت كثير
مبنيه عن على المجتمع المدني اللي كانوا
هم دكتوره درست المجتمع الفلسطيني من
زاويه امريكيه صرفه يعني يعني اليس للشعوب
تجربتها المختلفه في الديمقراطيه يعني
لانه كان في تعزيز
انه المجتمع المدني هو الحل للديمقراطيه
كان هذا هو الرافعه هو هذا المفهوم كان
معززين كثير بالغرب انت ليش تشوف انه دعم
الديمقراطيس للشرق
الاوسط كانت كلها يعني معنيه انه خلينا
ندعم المجتمع المدني خلينا ندعم الورك
شابس
شباب المراه المراه بس طبعا وفق المقاييس
الغربيه الامريكيه ايوه وخلينا نعطي عن
مفاهيم الديمقراطيه ونعلم الشعوب كيف نفهم
الثوره وانا كنت يعني كتير كنت انا سكبتكو
يعني
انت مختلفه مع هذا الامر تعتقد انه خطا
انه
كانت موجوده
المجتمع المدني كان قايم ومجتمع يعني كتير
فعال بس هم بيقولوا لا انه لا المشروب
العربيه مش مشاركه بالحياه السياسيه احياء
الاجتماعيه وحياه
مش فاعله في المنظمات
فايش لما انت بدك يعني بدك تناقش مع يعني
انه انه اوكي المجتمع المدني مش هالكثير
على الديمقراطيه بدك تكون في دراسه تكون
في الدراسه انك تثبت انه هاي الانديرس هاي
هاي
في في
اتفاق مع
الكيما الديمقراطيه في مفاهيم مع
الديمقراطيه كلها خلينا نروح نسوي بحث عن
شعوب العربيه ونفهم شو الكلمه
طيب انت عملتي هذه كله ماذا وجدتي وجدنا
انه
ما في
الشخص العربي في الدول العربيه او الشخص
الامريكاني في امريكا بتايده انه يكون في
ديمقراطيه انه يكون في انتخابات انه يكون
في حقوق انه يكون في رسبات للحقوق انه
يكون في ريسبات ايفل حقوق المراه وكذا
يعني ماني ماني عندك
مؤشرات
الراي يعني انها تعطينا فكره عن
السبورت بتلاقي انه الشعب العربي
الحريات اليوميه في الدول العربيه من قبل
الحكومات
عندك كمان عوائق الاكبر يعني احنا دائما
نحكي عن الحكومات بس خلينا كمان اعطي يعني
اسباب اخرى يعني احنا خلينا نوقف لحظه اذا
احنا بناخذ
احنا احنا في العلوم السياسيه احنا محللين
وبنكون في دراسات
وبنعطي فيريج وبنعطي
بس
احنا بنعرفها عن الديمقراطيه انه معظم
الحكومات الديمقراطيه اليوم عندها
يعني نسبيا للدول الاخرى ياس الجي دي بي
اللي هو
انه الفرص الاقتصاديه يعني الحياه
الاقتصاديه جيده جيده يعني تطلع الغرب
الاشارات الاقتصاديه عاليه ويعفي معظم
البلدان في البلدان امريكا اللي ضلوا
ديمقراطيه كانت كناميك احسن من اللي مكانه
افضل لما ناخذ كل العالم بتلاقي انه
ماشيه كويس في الدول اللي عندهم اقتصاد
ناجح
وبالتالي العالم العربي تظهر الاقتصاديه
تظهر مشكله
انتظرت المشكله الاقتصاديه الجامده اللي
احنا لازم ننتبه عليها واحنا لما انا كنت
اتفرج على اللي صار في تونس يعني بعد
الربيع العربي وكانوا كلنا هانعرف في
الغرب مبسوطين انه في دوله ديمقراطيه يعني
مبنيه على الانتخابات مش انتخابات مره
يعني بس يعني انتخابات مره واحده يعني
ثلاث انتخابات مضبوط يعني هذه كانت كثير
يعني نقطه مهمه نموذج
انه مش اول انتخابات اول انتخابات ثاني
انتخابات ثالث انتخابات ولكن الوضع
الاقتصادي في تونس من يوم الربيع العربي
للانتخابات اللي يعني كانت الله يعني اخر
انتخابات اللي
ديمقراطي
الحاله الاقتصاديه
من وقت الانتخابات الاخيره يعني انت لما
بدك تحكي عن الديمقراطيه والناس انها تكون
داعمه الخطه يصاحبها تطور اقتصادي لازم
يكون جبهه الثوره الاقتصادي
الانظمه المتعثره هي تؤدي الى تدهور
اقتصادي
على سبيل المثال من 2013 حتى اليوم
اقتصاديا تزداد سوء بسبب عدم الديمقراطي
تونس بسبب عدم الديمقراطيه وكمان بسبب
كمان عدم انه انه عدم التعزيز كمان مش بس
مضبوط انه الحكومات بتاثر
وكمان المساعدات اللي بتيجي من بره لما
انت تطلع المساعدات الغربيه
لدعم الديمقراطيه بالعربيه تكون اول اشي
مبنيه على سكيورتي ومش على تعزيز
الديمقراطي
من الاسس الامن هلا تونس يعني يعني
العلاقه الامريكانيه او الغربيه مع الدول
العربيه ليش مميزه لانه معظم العلاقات مش
مبنيه على تعزيز الديمقراطيه او تعزيز
للاجيال الجاي المبنيه العلاقات الاساسيه
على
الحقيقه من الحرب الثاني العالميه الثانيه
لليوم هذا المشكله اللي ابي اطرحها حاب
اطرحها معك دكتور انه نحاول ان ندرس
الواقع الديمقراطيه في العالم العربي
علميا ايه والحقيقه انه المساله السياسيه
صرفه طبعا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حينما دفعت قليلا باتجاه الديمقراطيه في
مصر وبعض دول العالم العربي حدث تغير
لكنها انتكست في هذا الموقف وهي ضد
الديمقراطيه يعني انت في كتابك الثاني
تتحدثين عن انه اما ديمقراطيه مواليه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه اولادي
ديمقراطي
كمان عده سنين بشرتيه او قالوا لنا
المجتمع اجتماعي المدني كل المشاكل
بالمجتمع
مشكله في المجتمع العربي
لما صارت عمليه
الربيع العربي
يعني شفت انه كان في مجموعه وانا نحكي في
مجموعه من الاكاديميين والسياسيين مبسوطين
انه الشعوب العربيه كانت بتطلب ولكن كثير
من الناس كمان كانوا يسالوا تبشرون عمليه
الديمقراطيه هاي رح تعني للعلاقات مع
امريكا في المستقبل والله
العلاقات او علاقات مع دول اخرى اللي هم
مضبوط فكان ايش صار كل شي بالبريزون انه
ايش شو المصلحه الاجنبيه الامريكانيه شو
المصلحه اسرائيل شو مصلحه ايران شو مصلحه
صار انه ايش العمليه الديمقراطيه متعلقه
بكل
استريجين فانا بالكتاب الثاني بدي اوضح
هذا
السبرتيز انه
برايمري جو
ليست هدفا هدفا
على استراتيجيات الغربيه
ومصلحات الغربيه اوكي هينا مشينا بالطريق
حتى لو ديمقراطيه مواليه المتحده الولايات
المتحده لماذا لا تدعم الامن الولايات
المتحده ديمقراطيه التابعه لها مثل
اليابان مثل دولات كوريا الجنوبيه لانه
لسه الغرب بيخافوا من لانه نرجع للنقطه
الاساسيه انه ما فيش ثقه
بالسلسن العربي
يشكل خطرا بالنسبه للغرب انت في في في
محاوله بحثك ايضا في مساله الربيع العربي
وقرات هذا الامر انه هل شجع الدين او احبط
المشاركه في الاحتجاج ضد الانظمه
الاستبداديه وفي الاستطلاعات اكتشفتي انه
الناس الذين لديهم ارتباط بالقران قراءه
ومعرفه هم اكثر نشاطا مع الديمقراطيه وفي
الاحتجاج الاسلاميون بشكل
[موسيقى]
يعني ما فيش حل فاحنا شو وجدنا انه الناس
اللي حكوا بالاستطلاعات انهم هم بيصلوا
بكروا القران
كانوا
شاركوا بالمظاهرات ليش لما سالنا قالوا
انه لانه
المظاهرات مبنيه على العدل والمفاهيم
الاسلاميه عندهم بالقران هل الاسلام مبني
على العدل يعني كانش اي علاقه بحركات
اسلاميه او كيف ميزته انهم مش اسلاميين
انهم ليسوا اسلاميه لانه بنسال اكثر
الاخوان المسلمين او لا او بتعيد
يعني يعني
احنا فانتم تسالون بحذر بحذر انه اننا
بنعرف احنا من الاسئله انه اوكي
بتتطبع اكثر اشي لحركه اسلاميه لتاييد
حركه اسلاميه اقرب للاسلاميين او للاخوان
لكن انتم ذهبتم للمسلمين للمسلمين ولقينا
ان الناس اللي بتكره قران وبتصلي يعني
قالوا انه احنا متدينه انهم كانوا مور
لايف مع الربيع مع الربيع العربي يعني هذه
لافته ايضا لانه فعلا القران يعني
والاسلام دين عدل دين مساواه ودين شورى
ودين ديمقراطيه بشكل يعني بشكل اخر يعني
عربيه لما بنسال الناس عن الديمقراطيه عن
حقوق الانسان عن العدل وبنسالهم عن
الاسلام كثير من الناس يقولوا الديمقراطيه
موجوده بالاسلام والاسلام موجوده في
الديمقراطيه يعني ولو ان هان بالغرب انه
في شكل
[موسيقى]
كانت الدكتوره اماني جمال واحده ممن اسسوا
مشروع الباروميتر العربي عام 2006 وما
زالت تتولى الاشراف عليه حتى اليوم وهو
كما يعرف عن نفسه اقدم واكبر مستودع
للبيانات المتاحه في متناول العامه بشان
اراء الرجال والنساء في المنطقه العربيه
ويجري المشروع موسوحه هو احصاءاته كل
عامين في 15 بلدا وخلال ست دورات اجرى 55
استطلاعا للراي تناولت موضوعات تتعلق
بمؤسسات الحكم والمشاركه السياسيه والتدين
والاحوال الاقتصاديه والمراه والاعلام
وغير ذلك
ويمنح مشروع الباروميتر العربي فسحه
للمواطنين العرب للتعبير عن ارائهم
ومخاوفهم ذات الصله بقضايا الحاضر
والمستقبل ويحاول التغلب قدر الاستطاعه
على المعوقات البيروقراطيه والامنيه التي
تعترض اجراء استطلاعات الراي في الدول
التي يشملها البحث المشروع نتاج جهد مشترك
بين جامعتي برينستون وميشيغان الامريكيتين
الى جانب مراكز بحثيه ومؤسسات علميه في كل
من الاردن وفلسطين وقطر وتونس فضلا عن
متخصصين اخرين يتخذون من الولايات المتحده
مقرا لهم
يحظى المشروع بتقدير عالم بين الاكاديمين
اذ يعدونهم مصدرا قيما للبحوث الساعيه الى
توصيف الراي العام وشرح اتجاهاته بشان
القضايا المهمه التي من شانها التاثير على
المنطقه العربيه وذلك من خلال ما يتيحهم
من بيانات للعامه والمتخصصين
[موسيقى]
السياسيه والديمقراطيه حياه حقوق المراه
الحقيقه
الاجتماعيه كمان يعني
معلومات
الانفورميشن والاخباريه اليوميه
بنسال عن
عن
مجالات المتوفره للشغل قضايا قضايا الدين
وقضايا الدين كلها موجوده بس
يعني بنجرب انه احنا
نفصلها عن بعضها بالاناناس تصفين
الباروميتر للمقربين بانه احد اطفالك كانه
طفل ابنك ليش
يعني انا
لانه وانا كنت طالب في الدكتوراه في مجال
الدكتوره
وحكيت لك انك كنت اقعد يعني اجلس
اسمع انه السبب اللي ما فيش
من المجتمع العربي اساسا المجتمع
الديمقراطيه بالانسان العربي
وان المفهومين مش موجوده عنا كنت كتير
تاثر
فش دراسات يعني عندك لا تستطيعين ان
تدافعين
ارقام مدري اراء ما في اراء او مواقفي وفي
عندك
مش موجود
العربي فانا بعد ما خلصت
الدكتوراه واشتغلت بلشت فيها
مع زملاء مع اكاديميين انه يعني يجب ان
يكون استطلاع راي عام للدول العربيه يعني
انه انه خاصه بعد احداث
انه ما يكونش عنا احنا نحكي عن
الشارع العربي طيب اجريته سبع دورات انتم
اول شيء اخذنا احنا صرنا اجرينا سبع دورات
بلشنا بالدور الاول بال 2000 حوالي 2006
هلا سبع دورات وبنجهز للدور الثامن كل
شغله كل سنتين كل سنتين كم بلد عربي
في اخر الدور السابع حوالي 13 بلد طيب من
اسس
علم المؤسسين بس هذا يحتاج للتمويل ودعم
هل هذه تكاليف
طبعا احنا الدعم لازم انك انت
تمويل والحمد لله تمويلنا اجى من كل اطراف
كثيره يعني من مؤسسات من معظمها من مؤسسات
تدعم الاكاديميه
في يعني في دعم اجانب من قطر من كندا من
اوروبا من امريكا من
يعني الحمد لله احنا مش من ايه
يخدم اطراف معينه يسيسوها
يعني يعني التمويل بيكون احسن ولا اكثر
ولا كذا ولا كذا بس احنا بنسكر تسهيلات
اكثر تسهيلات بس ابحثوا لنا في هذا
الموضوع
لها علاقه بالبراميه العرب
فهي تقف خلف هذا الاسئله حول القضايا بعض
القضايا يستلزم جراه عاليه جدا خاصه حول
المواقف السياسيه والمتعلقه بالحريات فحين
يسال مواطن عربي في بلد مستبد لا يستطيع
ان يقدم اجابه حقيقيه
مشكو
ك فيه كثير ناس بيقولوا
الصافي من المواطن العربي اول اشي احنا
يعني بنكون دايما معنا اثبات انه احنا
البرامج العربي مش معناه يعني ما بنشتغلش
لاي حكومه
ناخذش
انفرميشن من اللي بيشاركوا بالاستطلع
معلومات شخصيه مش موجوده
تطلع انت الاستطلاع الراي ما يعني مدينه
قمنا بالبحث بس ما بتعرفش وين يعني لما
اسال كشخص لا اقول انا فلان لا فاعطي فقط
رايي فانا فقط مواطن عربي تاخذون الجنس
والعمر
والمكان وين بسكنه بس بس بشكل عام بشكل
العواصب يعني برام الله برام الله فيها كم
الف واحد مضبوط
يخشى منها الانسان
فاول اشي
بنشتغل احنا في كل دوله مع مؤسسات معروفه
ومحترمه
نشتغل معهم مش مسيس
يعني احنا
بنت البلد
فتعرفون تماما
الجهات الحكوميه ما تتعاملهم على انه
دائما عندها الجهاد الحكمي بس ايش بنقول
للجهات الحكوميه اذا بعد ما نخلص البحث
بتحب نقدم لكم انا
بس يعني ولا حدا بيتدخل في الريبور تبعنا
طبعا تحتاج الى تصريح من الاجهزه الامنيه
ومرات بنست
جولات استطلاعيه كبيره وفي قضايا عده وعلى
مدى زمني طويل
تتشكل لديكم معرفه حقيقيه حول القضايا
الان في ما هي يعني الاشياء اللافته لك
انت كباحثه عربيه بحب اشوف الشباب شو وجهه
نظرهم متفائلين للمستقبل شو الفرص
الموجوده وللاسف اللي انا بشوفه يعني هلا
احنا بالدور الثامن حوالي 14 سنه نسبه
الشباب شبابنا العرب اللي بقولوا انهم
بفضلوا وبيحبوا انهم يتركوا البلدان
العربيه ويطلعوا على الغرب
بتزيد كل سنه للاسف
يعني احنا انا يعني فلسطينيه واضطريت اني
اطلع من بلدي بس مش حابه انه كل الناس
سجون وجحيم العرب اللي محم شهاده
الدكتوراه اللي موجودين برا الدول العربيه
حوالي هلا سبعين في المئه يعني
محللين
في الميه من العرب معهم في جديد
البلدان شبابنا الصغار الذين يشكلون طاقه
لسوق العمل وللتغيير والحيويه ينتظرون
لحظه الهجره ما فيش فرص عمل وفرص تعليم
انت بتعرف انه موسكي
لجميع يستطيع فانا
نرجع للاساس
عمليه التنميه السياسيه او عمليه تنميه
الديمقراطيه مبنيه انه يضل الشعب تبعنا
موجود في الدول العربيه ويبنوا
ولكن الفرس والاحوال اللي احنا فيها اليوم
ما بتاهلش الشباب للمستقبل وهذا اشي امانه
كتير
مؤلم بالنسبه لك كثير كثير طيب هذه
القضايا يعني لو سالت عربي ممكن يعطيك
رايي مشابه لهذا الراي هل في استنتاجات
تتعلق بالموقف من الديمقراطيه بعد الثوره
المضاده والانتكاسات وما جرى في سوريا ما
جرى في اليمن البلدان تقسمت يعني شوف كانت
تاييد للديمقراطيه تاييد عالي جدا في
الدول العربيه قبل الربيع العربي قبل قبل
يعني كانت 70 80% 80% من الشعوب العربيه
وبدهم المبادئ الديمقراطيه تكون موجوده
عندهم
ببلدانها ولكن بعد الربيع العربي الربيع
العربي
ازاي انت تفضلت صار استقرار في دول عديده
من من سوريا لليبيا صارت كوارث كوارث طبعا
كمان
يعني صار في تطور يعني
معظم البلدان العربيه فصارت الناس كمان
تقول انه مشينا في خطه الديمقراطيه وطلبنا
الديمقراطيه وجربنا وقمنا بالانتخابات
وشوف شو صار فهاي اول يعني
اكثر اهتمام يعني اكثر اهميه انه المواطن
العربي اللي سكن في بلد مشت في طريقه
الديمقراطيه او في طريقه الانتخابات
انتخابات بعد الربيع العربي الوضع
الاقتصادي اليومي ساء
في نموذج تونس تونس
اولها
يعني اولا
المغرب
رئاسه الوزراء والحكومه وتشكيل
شايفين عمليه ديمقراطيه بس مش تغيير نظام
ده ليس تغيير فضلت احوال الاقتصاديه افضل
من المغرب فالس
افضل من دول الاخرى
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي في المغرب اكثر من الناس هذا
الدكتوره يدفعني الى انه الان نستمع الى
حديث الناس احنا جزء من المجتمع انه اذا
كانت الديمقراطيه ستجلب كل هذا الدمار
والكوارث نريد استقرار ونريد امن لا نريد
ديمقراطي طبعا هي تجربه كوارث لانه
الانظمه لا تريد ديمقراطي مستعده للحروب
يعني اقصد السبب بس في نهايه المطاف الدول
غير الديمقراطيه المستقره باتت كانها افضل
من الدول التي حدثت فيها حركات ثوريه او
مظاهرات هاي النقطه صارت مهمه جدا واللي
صار يعني اللي مبين هلا النقطه
التاريخي اللي احنا مجرمين فيها بتاخذ دول
الصين
الصين بالالفين بالسنه الالفين كان
للفاملي الف دولار بالشهر تحت
20 سنه
الانش جي تي بي للفاملي تشارلي 12,000
دولار
اشوف قديش سنه طيب ما كانه هذا صار مؤشر
انه بيجوز الديمقراطي دول الخليج دول
الخليج
الناس عايشه ومكيفه وحقوقها جيتها بدون
ديمقراطيه
ووضعهم الاقتصادي منيح فهلا هاي لما احنا
بنحكي اليوم اندم
وتراجع بالعالم مش بس دول العربيه انه هذا
النقطه انه في ماضل اقتصادي ناجح مش مبني
على الديمقراطيه وهذا واضح في روسيا في
الصين في الصين في تركيا لحد ما في
ديمقراطيه لكن يعني في ثبات بس في نجاح
اقتصادي في
انه تعزيز الديمقراطيه مش لما فقيامه قلب
نهايه التاريخ وكل هذا لا الان احنا هذا
الدكتوره اللي احنا يعني وشخصين حتى تتحدث
عنه اكثر من مره انه واضح انه نشا موديل
جديد انظمه جديده قد تكون اكثر اغراء صحيح
هل هذا يعني في استطلاعاتكم الدائمه هل
يبدو هذا واضحا مئه بالمئه من رغبه
الجمهور العربي
اقصد الجمهور العام جمهور العربي لما احنا
بدنا نطلع الاستطلاعات الراي والاشارات
نسبه العرب اللي هلا بايدوا حكومه يتراسها
كرجمتك او ديكتاتور
اقتصاد ناجح ولو انه فيش حقوق الديمقراطيه
في تاييد كثير لهذا النظام الماضي الجديد
اللي هو ماشي على الاقل يكون بس اجراءاته
شوي يعني خفيفه
انشات ايضا مختبره افغانستان بعد احتلالها
كثير من
بعد
الانسانه
يشتغلوا بالحكومه الافنيه
طبعا نجحوا ونزحوا عاد الطالبا
[موسيقى]
الاكاديميه مرتبطه بالانشطه كانه احنا
حاله الدول الاستعماريه الكبرى ماذا ماذا
كانت تفعل ان النشاط الاكاديمي الى جنب مع
الاهتمامات السياسيه امريكا تهتم بالعالم
العربي يكون هناك في افغانستان يكون هناك
دراسات واحنا دائما احنا احنا يعني هلا
بالمدرسه بنحب
دراستنا موجوده في كل كل العالم مش بس في
افغانستان وشرق الاوسط ان احنا عنا خبره
بالكليه
بلافريقيا بروسيا باوروبا
ولكن ايش من الاهم يعني أقليس من وجهه
نظري
بدناش دايما بس ندرس المناطق اللي بتهم
سياسه امريكا وليش انا مركز انه لازم الان
يعني نركز كمان على افريقيا ونركز على ولو
انه هلا يعني
على افغانستان
انه المفروض علينا اننا نكون موجودين
وفي كل العالم
ما درست موقف النص في العالم العربي من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني بنعرف
انه
يعني الشعوب العربيه
نسال الشهو رايكم بسياسه الامريكانيه في
الدول العربيه طبعا ما فيش تاييد
لما بنسالهم عن حريات الموجوده في امريكا
الفرس الموجوده في امريكا عن الشعوب
الامريكانيه في تاليف في في يعني محبه
موده يعني هذا واضح الناس تحب الحياه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والحريات وفرص
العمل لكن مشكله امريكا والديمقراطيه لكن
مشكله امريكا لا تقدم هذا في العالم
العربي تقدم الديكتاتوريه والاستبداد
وتدعم القمع وتدعم التخلف وتدعم كل شيء
سلبيا يعني شوف يعني لا يشكل خطر على
امريكا يعني المشكله انه بترجع النقطه
للعلاقات الاستراتيجيه
لانه بضل تخاوف من الشعب العربي والشعب
المسلم
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
بضل انه في
يعني في
كوبايه انه لا ادعموا الحكومات الموجوده
احسن من اللي راح يجيكم بعد الحكومات هاي
بنحطه في استطلاعات تحدثت عن موقف الشعب
الامريكي انه اذا في احتماليه لظهور زعيم
اسلامي عبر الديمقراطيه فالافضل ان لا
ندعم بالديمقراطيه صحيح اذا الديمقرا يعني
عمليه دعم الديمقراطيه سواء الرسميه او
الشعبيه مرتبطه بنتائجها وصار الشعب
العربي مزبوط الشعب العربي بيعرف انه
الشعب العربي بعرف انه امريكا يعني اهداف
امريكا بالشرق الاوسط اهداف امريكانيه لكن
صار في طبقه من الشعوب العربيه كمان يعني
مستعده تمشي مع الخطه هاي وتؤيد يعني
مع خطه الامريكانيه من شان بتخاف من او
بتخاف من الرده الفعل الامريكانيه لما
يكون حركه سياسيه او نتيجه سياسيه مش
مطابقه للاستراتيجيات الامريكانيه في
الشبكه الاوسط هل استطلعت تشير عن الحركات
الاسلاميه دكتوره في العالم العربي مواقف
الناس منها المواطنين منها
العربي فمعظم البلدان كنا نشوف حوالي انه
في تاييد للحركات الاسلاميه
من 30 الى 60% هذا قبل الربيع العربي قبل
الربيع العربي هل اجريت هذا الامر بعد
الربيع العربي
معظم الحكومات يعني طلبوا منا ما نسالش
السؤال هذا اول اشي او الاسئله بس كمان في
صار يعني الوضع للحركات الاسلاميه بعد
الربيع العربي
معظم الحركات الاسلاميه يعني
انه خاطر انه الناس الناس كمان ما بتحبش
تجاوب السؤال هذا وبالتالي من الصعب
استطلاع مثل هذا الامر اذا الاستطلاع يعني
ايضا استطلاعات الراي تواجه صعوبات كبيره
في قضيه يعني النتائج القضيه في القضيه
القضيه مرتبطه بالحكومات وفي المعارضه
كثير صعب
الكتاب الثاني كان عن الامبراطوريه
والمواطنين ما هي قصه وحكايه الكتاب الاخر
يعني الكتاب يعني
انه
يعني مش انه لازم بس ناخذ ان الطاقه
الديمقراطي بين المواطن والحكومه او
المواطن والمواطنين الاخرى المواطن العربي
كمان بعرف انه في حكومات اخرى تتدخل
بالحياه اليوميه السياسيه وانه يعني لما
هم بيروحوا
يعني احنا يعني
اعطيك مثل يعني احنا لما يروحوا او
بيطلبوا في الديمقراطيه هلقيت صاروا
يحسبوا حساب عوامل اخرى يعني خذ الوضع
الفلسطيني هلا الفلسطيني مقامش في
انتخابات
مضبوط من 2006 بعدها حدث اللي في حماه في
غزه
انتخابات ولما نسال الشعب الفلسطيني هم
مؤيدين طبعا حقوق انسان طبعا
من الانتخابات فهمان الى الخوف انه ايش
انها النتيجه اللي بتطلع من الانتخابات
تيجي حماس ايش اذا حماس ايش انه الدعم
الامريكاني للسلطه الاستقلال الموجود في
فلسطين انه كله راح يكون
[موسيقى]
افضل انه نضل بدون انتخابات
فلسطيني او عربي عربي بمعنى انه المواطن
العربي اصبح يعني هو يعيد الديمقراطيه
لكنه لا يفضل نتائج الديمقراطيه تكون غير
مواليه المتحده الامريكيه او حتى لا يتوقف
الدعم او تتاثر او تتاثر او علاقه
الاقتصاديه العلاقات الاقتصاديه يعني او
انه يصير استقرار من خلال المداخله
بالنسبه للموقف
غير الدعم من امريكا للديمقراطيات هل
استطلعت راي الناس فيه يعني هل الناس ترفض
هذا الموقف تشتري موقف الامريكي الذي لا
يدعم ديمقراطيه مواليه له يعني في كثير
ناس رافضين هاي الفكره بس كمان بقولوا
احنا احنا رافضين بالواقع حقوق قدامنا
يعني شو بدنا نسوي يعني في شويه يعني
واقعيه واقعيه انه يعني
من يستفيد من نتائج البارومتر على لم اسال
هذا السؤال يعني التقارير التحليليه في
غايه الاهميه الولايات الحكومه الامريكيه
تستفيد منها الله اعلم احنا بنعرف انه
كثير ناس من العالم وفي الولايات المتحده
من قبل الحكومه
الميديا
مش بس بالوقت المتحده باوروبا وكمان في
الدول العربيه يعني
بنسمع انه الحكومات كمان نفسها بتطلع على
تبعونا يعني كثير مفهومه منيح عن الوضع
السياسي والاقتصادي يعني معلنه وتقارير
اخرى مثلا بالطلب ممكن تطلب يعني احنا
تحليليه احنا بنسوي دائما التحليل تبعنا
موجود على الويب سايت تبعهم تبعنا بالعربي
وبالانجليزي يعني وبنحب كثير انه الشعب
العربي نفسه يستفيد من رابط الموقع يعني
للمشاهدين العربي المهتمين وللطلبه
الباحثين مهم مهم جدا
اذا المعلومات هي الموجوده على الموقع لا
يوجد تحليل معمق اكثر لا لا يعني ادينا
موجوده اللي ياخد الدائره
تحليل لحاله كمان واحنا يعني
تقدمون الكثير والتقارير تعتمدون على
مؤسسات محليه تساعدكم وباحثين عرب
طيب دكتور وصلنا لختام الحلقه الثانيه
هذا المشوار الاكاديمي الذي توج بالعماده
عماده واحده من اهم كليات الشؤون العامه
والدوليه وكذلك هذا المشوار البحثي في
مساله الديمقراطيه ومعوقات الديمقراطيه ما
هي الخلاصات والنتائج التي وصلت لها انت
امان الجمال يعني
متفائله ودائما بتطلع الشعوب شبابنا
وشباتنا وعندي تفائل كثير في قدرتهم
واحنا طبعا لازم انه نضل يعني
محافظه على الاستمرار في الاجراءات تجاه
التحول الديمقراطي
وربما ربما راح يعني يعني
الديمقراطيه ممكن تكون يعني قابل للتطبيق
بيجوز مش مستحيل ولكن احنا كشعوب بدنا نظل
نمشي بهذا الخطه
اي نظام لازم تكون انفستد لازم تكون عندها
مع شعبها ان تستثمر
بجوز الدول كلها مش قادرين بجوز
ليس اولويه ايوه الاولويه ولكن في شيء
يعني يعني اذا بتطلع على التاريخ
الصوت المواطنين مهم في اي حكومه او شكلها
حكومي هذه الرساله نتمنى ان تصل يعني
الاستثمار في الشعوب وخاصه انه في حاله
انكسار بعد الربيع العربي ولكن الاستقرار
ايضا مطلبه مهم وبالتالي يمكن الدمج كل
هذه الامور ان تستثمر هذه الحكومات في
شعوبها وتبني عمليه اصلاحها لو تدريجيه
والناس تريد النجاح الناس ليست اعداء
للانظمه او اعداء للحكومات يعني الناس لما
بدها تكون الاكسبرينسيس تبعونها
منيحه وتوفر لاولادها مستقبل
هايل مستقبل جيد طيب انت نجحت اليوم في
المهجر كمهاجره فلسطينيه بماذا تنصحين
الشباب العربي ايضا على عتاب التخرج من
الجامعه من الثانويه ان يسيروا في طريق
الهجره
يعني مش مش ضروره انهم يصيروا في خطه
الهجره انه كمان يستثمروا في بلدانهم
اذا هاجروا يرجعوا على بلدانهم
اذا هاجروا ياخذوا هالعلم ويرجعوا بلدانهم
ويبنوا بلدانهم
هذا يطرح عليك
ما هو ان شاء الله احنا ان شاء الله
بكلنا دوله وبنرجع عليها
والدوليه في جامعه بيرلنستون هذا الصرح
الاكاديمي الاستثنائي اللي دائما يحصد
الارقام المتقدمه من بين الجامعات
الامريكيه نشعر بالفخر ان ابنه هذا ابنه
فلسطين والعالم العربي تكون في هذا الموقع
وساعدين ان تكوني ايضا انك كنت في
المقابله في جزئين الله يخليك شكرا
تعبتي من استخدام اللغه العربيه لا لا بس
بدي اركز مرات ازبط الكلمه انا اعتقد ان
الافكار واصله
بشكل ممتازه
ليش ما حكيتيش بالانجليزي
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتورة
مشاهدينا الكرام شكرا جزيلا لكم انتم على
طيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله في
الاسبوع المقبل وحلقه جديده من المقابله
دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]